This is my perfect lasagna.
Start by finely chopping onion, carrots, and celery.
Add the mirepoix to a large pot with butter and oil, and sauté.
Add in the seasonings and follow with tomato paste
stirring constantly, until you see it darken in color.
The sugars will caramelize, adding richness and reducing acidity.
Next, add ground beef, ground pork, and pancetta
and allow the heat to reduce the sugars and proteins, browning our meat.
This is known as the maillard reaction.
Add milk, wine, and bring to a simmer, and add some oregano.
Now, for the ricotta béchamel.
Start with butter in a pan over medium-low heat.
Stir in the flour and whisk constantly for one minute.
The process of combining fat and flour creates a thickening agent for our sauce.
Now, add the milk and bring to a simmer.
Stir in the salt and nutmeg and let cool before folding in the ricotta cheese.
Slice three al dente noodles lengthwise to help fit the pan, and let's assemble.
Start with the béchamel, then noodles. Add another layer of ricotta béchamel, then the bolognese.
Add some parmesan cheese and top with one more layer of noodles.
And repeat.
Top with a final layer of béchamel, parmesan, and mozzarella.
Bake this uncovered for 40 minutes.
And wow, look at that.
Almost perfect.
So, what makes it perfect?
Well, the best thing about lasagna is that it can be built however you want.
Perfect is in the eye of the beholder.